give me a hardtop with a decent engine
and make sure that it's got a big trunk
that's a weird Irish way to do it give
me a hardtop with a decent engine make
sure that it's got a big trunk what is
it like British guy but with like kind
of the accent becomes a night he's
British and he's doing an American
accent which makes him sound kind of
Irish it's we're just so angle
hello hi ladies and rejects this is your
host and charming mother effing [ __ ]
greg alba here and i'm john i and ii
Rick I'm ready I'm a Jaffa Peterson the
robot with the mohawk so we watched the
BMW felt like John and I when we were
younger really like the the series of
the BMW films a lot of people who
weren't introduced to Clive oh and God
introduced the clive owen through that
yeah the higher right yeah the higher
was like a collection of eight films my
sister showed me that she got the DVD
and then I thought it was awesome and
thus like I think it goes out for free
at one point I think you can just let
your way lbm dumping that you went it's
like BMW like just kick off you with you
yeah it was I think they charge like a
little bit but i think it was yeah like
you could just go on their website and
request a copy yeah those were really
cool and those were awesome and then
because of that a lot of people were
like hoping that he that clever would be
the next James Bond and clive owens had
a pretty awesome career since then it
hasn't quite been on the you know the
highest points i think a lot people
expecting him to be at a higher level by
now or a higher caliber yes hasn't made
some of the greatest films he's still
been a great actor it's just the film's
a lot of his films overall had not been
that well received one climb owns ago it
seems like he's always good in stuff
like he's always a high point in
whatever movies in but yeah it's like
it's special in the last couple of years
I've been wondering where he's been like
yeah a little surprised not to have seen
him cuz I don't feel like there's really
any reason we shouldn't see more of
Clive Owen but I was really happy when
they decided to return to this cuz this
is something I think is actually really
cool the whole marketing gimmick of
featuring a BMW in there I'm not
annoying it's not honestly like I I
would rather it be in this I'd rather
BMW go look we want to showcase our cars
with some cool action scenes yeah like
make us a short film I think that's
better even a commercial and B then
stopping like a James Bond movie to go
look BMW come right oh yeah but that
like 10 minute window where they switch
master Martin's to BMWs yeah here's
brother nor I'm like you know where they
do like a very big close-up on the BM
you okay yeah and so yeah I'm like I
would rather do this work I get the
sense these filmmakers got a chance to
do something cool like it can't be hard
as a filmmaker to work around the caveat
of ya do whatever you want to just
showcase our car a little bit yeah
absolutely yeah I really wow really like
this one I think it's a great
reintroduction into it oh I you know I
feel like there's gonna be better once
to come but there's a lot of cool things
in here neill blomkamp directed this one
and you got Vera Farmiga in here Dakota
Fanning Jon Bernthal of course Clive oh
and returning Clive oh and still pretty
cool dude does look older it's been a
few years yeah knows that was actually
because we've been talking about clever
now actually made this a little more
special to me watching it so like when
he rolled up I was excited yeah you know
like oh yeah like I missed cuz I haven't
seen these in a long time so I missed
him as the drives been a lot of movies
that have like the driver character yeah
and he is one of the cool like one of
the best ones to me yeah like to me like
Jason Statham's transporter is a lot
like a driver no it has a name and stuff
that kind of comes to mind here is
transporter when I watch this because
you know this guy this youjizz drano
he's just a driver for people but he's a
really skilled driver be yeah yeah he's
one of those guys who you believe gets
by but having a very strict set of rules
yes you know pretty common less those
rules get broke when the film starts
author they establish out there working
on genetic engineering and you even get
like the coolest abla shot of the like
specimens of the little humans are
making her or ones that went wrong or
something yeah the genetic sort of
modifications they've been doing these
you know fringe experiments and it's
cool and neill blomkamp did that because
a lot of people want to hear neill
blomkamp i think of his first film
that's usually halos his best district
nine yeah and one thing district nine
did really well was it blended the world
of alien something totally sci-fi in the
realm of reality yeah and this isn't too
far fetched from reality yeah it's it's
it's he's playing more to the tone down
inside of the sci-fi spectrum but it
still got that sign you on campus I high
twist yeah exactly and I feel like yeah
cuz this is a smaller film it's a
smaller sci-fi but it's still you know
it's still got his stamps on it but in
yeah and it also allows for a character
moat motives a moment in here it's cool
coming back to these after so long
because you see climb on you see the his
age and now to have this being sort of
more futuristic environment there's not
like a ton of character in all these
little shorts but it does kind of give
it a sense of story you know yeah wow
this guy has to adapt a sort of
futuristic world yeah how are these
things or things you might have to
encounter in his business they haven't
had a moment where Clive Owen says jon
bernthal in the car like I'm a little
rusty yeah currently and I don't know I
just feel like a little touch like that
was nice because like I said this is a
cool reintroduction story to him I
wonder if they're gonna do it a little
bit different because I don't know if
they're gonna try to make it a little
more cereal instead of just there's one
thing that's cool is they do they're all
pretty much action short films yeah but
they're a different style still
depending especially when the director
it gets to add his own unique flavor to
it yeah there there's usually a cross of
genres in there and here's like the
sci-fi action one that's great because
we didn't get sci-fi action on recalling
the higher we got like supernatural one
where he like takes on the devil yeah
but we didn't get a science fiction one
yet so to have a cool little sci-fi
short film here was great I really think
it's cool that they got like really
credited really reputable actors to
being here because John bertles role is
not exactly written as the most in-depth
role but because you get it actor like
Jon Bernthal who loves to create history
and loves to create such in depth
character you feel this whole history
you feel a unique touch to a character
that a lot of people might are you
saying any guy could play that who's
like kind of tough and brooding but he
does have his own touch to the role
because you could feel the history is
created there when this is something to
that I like seeing neill blomkamp dude
cuz like this has a lot of earmarks of
his style and things he likes to play
with you know like there's this kind of
shadowy military corp vs you know a sort
of solo guy I think this is a cool place
for for him to kind of practice this
stuff his last couple movies have been
received in a sort of shaky way so this
is sort of like a more down-to-earth
sort of exercise almost that I felt was
cool to watch you know it's well usually
when I
director starts off like with exploring
some type of fiction like really
fictional kind of genre whether it be
sci-fi or fantasy they tend to go down a
path where they get a little too carried
away or indulgent with something like
that and then people tend to complain
that they lose sight of the story so
it's cool to see us a small little short
film worry it's not filled with a
character background an exposition but
there's still attention to detail within
each of the characters even even the
specimen character Lily played by the
Kota Fanning I mean she's cool I've
never been the biggest Dakota Fanning
fan yeah Fanning fan Fanny Betty fun
what if any fence membership come yeah I
mean I felt like she was really cool
when she was a little kid cuz it was
like your little kid who behaves like a
30 year old yeah yeah here like 18 or
however old she is on now you're an
adult I don't really feel anything
special in her roles lately but she does
have like that kind of she's not
unattractive but she does have this like
alien look about her like some kind of
like in a good way i could've been doing
like a Tim Burton yeah exactly in the
exact same way I think like olivia wilde
she's hot but she also has kind of an
alien look about her and that's kind of
how i feel about Dakota Fanning so I
thought she was well cast for the role I
liked what she did with this kind of
character cuz it is a sci-fi type of
character you know sort of genetically
engineered yeah person thing who has to
act like everything is kind of foreign
and I like what she brought to that yeah
cuz it's a hard world to play and it's a
cool role for it was a cool new look
into the driver character yeah where he
takes sympathy for a child because even
though she you know he seems like he is
aware that she is not a you know
natural-born human yeah that he still
sees the soul in her that's always been
the cool part of the driver this little
short has a good amount of plot for you
know yeah just how quick it is like it
feels just like a very immediate
situation that takes a few turns and so
in that way too I like seeing neill
blomkamp work in a sort of contained
fashion like that yeah just as a sort of
reminder I thought just the production
values and stuff and the action were
really cool and the only thing I'm
it was like I wish that the car chase
had actually been a little bit more of
like an awesome looking car chase
because like what I got was that was the
impact that's not like a fault with it
but it was just something I was kind of
missing I guess was like I felt the
impact of a lot of those crashes and
stuff like that but like the actual like
[ __ ] that's a cool card yes was a little
tone down for me I tend to appreciate a
cool car chase over explosions on the
freeway yeah you know and then there's a
lot of that year no maybe it takes on a
helicopter one point that was one of
those things you I was like I don't know
if this is realistic anymore that is
cool like it is [ __ ] cool like I
would give it I was watching going yeah
it still wowed me even if it is a little
big but it looks like they really
flipped over that that giant truck yes I
have it like it looked like they had a
camera attached to the side of the truck
and they had that uh I kinda like a
GoPro shot of it ya doin underneath the
bridge which was really cool there there
action it took me a little longer to
appreciate with this one I guess because
some of them some of them in the first
installment of the series and also this
is our first introduction are they do we
know if they're gonna make me like
they're making more yeah so maybe this
is just a new introduction to the style
but it took me a little longer to
appreciate what they did with the action
because it is it is more sort of like
the sheer amount of physical what looked
like real stunts they were doing so it's
like the stunts are really cool and
those all involve the car and stuff like
that so it's not the most like sleekly
shot car chase but man like when they
flip that truck over and when there are
like Humvees crashing indo chosen like
you do it is kind of awesome and that
way is wow they really went to the
trouble of doing some stunts and that
was cool to see I like that a lot of
people I remember when the higher came
out a lot of people were hoping that
like are they gonna like try to make a
real show out of this or a real movie as
cool as a lot of this would be cool to
seen on the big screen I think that a
show or movie would ruin it oh well
actually this should stay what it is
because I feel like this is a cool thing
that I mean I haven't seen I don't know
what the rest of these are gonna look
like now that are bringing it back but I
remember watching the higher and it
really did feel like [ __ ] tony
scott's movie was him racing the devil
like gary oldman like it with like his
style
cranked up to ya like crazy music video
kind of editing yeah it was nuts and
that's that's what I feel like is part
of the inherent charm of these films and
why yeah I kind of want them to stay on
this level and not become I feel like it
would spoil it to make it a real movie
because the charm of these shorts is
that it's a variety and it's a different
genre blending I feel like you would
have to conform to kind of just one
genre blend what I were to make a whole
feature work I gotta imagine that if you
want to make something like this you're
not every car company does this so it's
like if you are invested in making
something like this I think you have to
have an interest in like letting these
guys cut loose and make some cool [ __ ]
yes that's rate of freedom in there yeah
cuz that's what these all feel like is
like ah this director and a good cat got
together and made a really cool short
that they wouldn't have been able to
make if it was a whole me exactly so
like that's that's the most exciting
thing about all these to me is sort of
like oh what's the style and what's the
you know hook gonna because they're
always creative well rating system time
mating system time I say this is great
great too great too good great great too
good no this is under the great this is
pretty great it's not quite fantastic or
amazing yeah yeah but it's better than
good it's great yeah let's happy to see
Clive Owen back i was happy to see neill
blomkamp back and just kind of you know
doing his thing and jon bernthal zanmi
is the second role i've seen jon
bernthal in where he gets his ass handed
to him when he's supposed to be a
top-notch Pro yeah be accounted in this
alright guys subscribe to the reject
channel make sure to wipe and John is on
facebook.com slash blue house is
literally rejects